يوم فارسي طويل ومطرب اعتداء على مركز
كردي في العاصمه اودى بحياه ثلاثه اشخاص
الاذنات الشديده لما وقع من السلطات
الفرنسيه لم تتاخر لكنها لم تاخر ما كانت
تخشاه الحشود الكرديه الغاضبه بدات تتجمع
تمهيدا لتظاهرات تحولت الاحتجاجات
واشتباكات
وزير الداخليه زار المكان وحاول السباق
الاحداث جلال دار معنا قال انه امر كافه
اجهزه الشرطه بحمايه مناطق تواجد الجاليه
الكرديه
امرت اجهزه الشرطه في باريس وفي اماكن
اخرى من التراب الوطني بحمايه الاماكن
التي تتجمع فيها الجاليه الكرديه
كلام وزير الداخليه لم يكن كافيا لتفادي
اعمال شغب ومواجهه واشتباكات مع الشرطه
الفرنسيه التي عززت حضورها لا سيما في
منطقه ستراسبورغسان دوني حرق للحاويات
وتكسير
[تصفيق]
الشرطه
للدموع لتفريغ المتظاهرين الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل
حادث اطلاق النار
الذي استهدف اكراد فرنسا
غير ان المواجهات لم تتوقف الصور تلخص ما
حدث وتنذر بما قد يحدث
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]